came away feeling very positive I mean
first of all you know thank you to the
Prime Minister and his team for finding
the time to talk to us about this today
let's put it this way the outsider
society who were now ambassadors for
have been saying for a very long time
that something needs to be done
especially around social care concerning
people living with dementia and
Alzheimer's for some reason it seems if
you have a different kind of illness
you're taken care of and you know the
NHS will look after you but for some
reason dementia seems to be a bit
different so for instance people with
dementia will have to pay 15 percent
higher for Social Care than if you were
living with another disease now
obviously no one wants to get this and I
think all of us would say that no one
must be penalized for having a certain
condition ok what did the Prime Minister
have to say he was very he's told us
he's very committed to fixing this
problem he he listened you know there
were representatives from the outside of
society there with Barbara and I and
everyone said exactly why we need this
to happen I mean what the outside of
society are asking for is that there's
an urgent NHS dementia fund set up that
would be a start and that we all realize
that you know the social care problem is
across the board it affects all
illnesses in social care for people to
deal with it it's not going to happen
overnight we know that you know no one
can fix this overnight but certainly we
shouldn't have one set of people
excluded because they have this
condition and we have to bring the
playing field level and they certainly
need to look at dementia in a different
way and it needs to be quite urgent it
really does we have to get something
going we know it's not going to be
happening straightaway how how would you
see the funding being used what what is
the money best used for if it becomes
available would you say
well if the money becomes available you
know it's going to be best used to see
to sue each individual person's
immediate needs I mean there may be
things that need doing to the house
alterations that need doing to the house
there may be things like stair lifts
need to be put in you know electric
sockets might have to be altered there
are apart from the hands-on care of
people being made sure everyone's okay
that they're taking their medication
that they haven't had an accident in the
night there is so many different areas
where this is going to be used and at
the moment it is not available you know
families are having to give up their
jobs to look after their loved ones
there also in cases having to sell their
homes I mean I met an 80 year old lady
two weeks ago in Bristol a lovely lady
called Val whose partner is in a care
home and her partner's savings have gone
Belle's savings are dwindling very fast
and she said to me and these are people
that have worked their whole lives paid
into a system and this Val said to me
one options got is I may have to sell my
home and I'm 80 years of age and this
there's no backup plan as I say the
prime minister said he is committed to
fix this problem and I I hope my truly
hope that he will follow this through
and act as urgently as possible lovely
to see pictures of you in the Downing
Street garden with your beautiful
beautiful wife how is she
Barbara you know she puts on a really
brave face especially when we go out she
snaps back into that Barbara Windsor
I know it's expected of me to put on a
little front it's not as easy as it used
to be okay you know for instance on the
way down to Downing Street
I must have explained to her about eight
times where we were going and why we
were going because the nature of
Barbara's condition at the moment is you
know she instantly forgets things now of
an evening she constantly will ask me
when we're going home or where are we or
why are there pictures of us in this
place and of course we sit we're sitting
in our front room people who are caring
for people with Alzheimer's and dementia
will identify with this straightaway for
those of you that can't identify with
this I pray that you never have to go
through it
I pray it never affects you but I'm
afraid to say that one in three people
born today will develop dementia at some
point in time you're going to come
across someone you know whether it be a
friend or a family member that will
develop dementia and that's why it's so
important now and for future generations
that the government acts on this and get
something in place for people that you
know are already struggling to deal with
this illness anyway is hard enough I
promise you and I'm in a very privileged
situation where we don't have to worry
about financial side at this moment but
there are people who really are
struggling financially so to have that
stress on top of what you're living with
must be absolutely unbearable